[Alkış]
Merhabalar Hoş geldiniz
Hülya Tiritoğlu ben
burada bu konuşmayı yapmamın sebebi hep
hayallerimde olan
hayallerimin üstünde gerçekleşen
kurucusu olduğum markanın Doğuş
hikayesini anlatmak için geldi
girişimciliğim ilk işim daha önce bir İş
tecrübem yoktu mesleğim de yoktu benim
ama Çalışkan çalışan üretken bir kadın
olmak istiyordum
çalışan iş kadınlarına bakıyorum
imreniyordum ilham alıyordum
kayseri'liyim
Kayseri'de doğdum büyüdüm Kayseri'de
yaşıyorum kökleri geçmişe dayanan
Kayserili bir ailenin kızıyım ve
geliniyim
Kayseri ticaretiyle ünlü bir şehir bizim
ailede de evde de hep Ticaret
konuşulurdu hep ön plandaydı Benim babam
da Kayseri'de ticaretiyle ün yapmış bir
iş adamı
liseyi bitirir bitirmez evlendi iki kız
çocuğum var Benim çocuklar büyürken
kendi kişisel gelişim için kurslara
gitmeye başladım bir kurs bitiyor biri
başlıyordu bir kurs bitiyor biri
başlıyordu
ama Mutlu değildim ben bir şeyler yapmak
istiyordum üretmek istiyordum
ne yapabilirim diye araştırdım ben ne iş
yapabilir
iş fikirlerini buluyordum aile toplanır
Ben İş fikrini açıklarım
ama hep şu cevapla karşılaşıyordum sen
kızların daha küçük Sen çocuklarını
büyüt
veya bu iş fikri tutmaz sen bundan para
kazanacağını düşünüyorsun diyorlardı
bana ama pes etmiyordum
başka iş fikirleri çıkıyordu başka iş
fikirleri buluyordum bu süreç böyle bir
devam etti
çocuklar ortaokul dönemine geldiğinde
eşimi ikna etmeyi başarmıştı
Bu arada iş aramam garip gelebilir Çünkü
benim babamın fabrikaları ve çeşitli
sektörlerde iş yerleri vardı
Anadolu'da kadının ihtiyacı yoksa
çalışmasına gerek yoktur Biz Anadolu'da
Ataerkil bir toplumda yaşıyoruz
geleneklerimize çok bağlıyız
aileye çok önem veriyoruz muhafazakarız
ve benim de çevremde Ailemde çalışan bir
iş kadını modeli yoktu
eşimi ikna etmeyi başarmıştım 2010
yılında başladı çemensin hikayesi
babamın üreticisi olduğu et ürünlerini
satış noktası ile başladım bu işe Ben
tabi biliyorsunuz pastırma sucuk yöresel
ürünümüz ve çok değerli çok kıymetli
eskiden beri 1800 yıllarından beri
Biz bu işi uğraşıyoruz pastırma sucuk
imalatı ve üretimi Kayseri'de 1800
yıllarından beri yapılmış bu ticarette
ve ciddi et kombinaları var gerçekten
çok özel ürünler ve bunlar eskiden beri
tarihten beri gelen çarşının içinde
şehir merkezinde
dükkanlarda satılır böyle pastırma
sucuğu görmüşsünüzdür ipleri asılır
çengellerle hep sergilenir dükkanların
önlerinde ilk işin bu ürünleri hijyenik
ve şık dolaplarının içine almak oldu
gerçekten çok yöreselde Bu ürünler ve
çok özeldi şehrinizi özel kültürel
mirasımızda Bunlar çok daha iyi
sergilenmeli paketlenmeli ve
müşterilerle buluşmalıydı
bu iş dünyada nasıl yapılıyor diye
araştırdığımda o zaman baktım ki
sağlıklı doğal ürünler satan dükkanlar
vardı Gurme dükkanlar açılmıştı Biz çok
şanslıydık ülkemizin çeşit çeşit yöresel
bir sürü yöresel doğal ürünleri vardı
araştırmaya başladım
seyahatlerim başladı Kars'tan
Diyarbakır'a
Çanakkale'den Edremit Ayvalık bölgesine
uzanan
iş seyahatlerin başladı artık ailecek
Biz tatillerimizde iş seyahatlerim
olarak yapıyorduk bu arada
tabi Bunun yanı sıra diğer Şarküteri
ürünleri de gelmeye başladı Tabi o
dönemde bu ürünler satmaz Niye bu
ürünleri getiriyorsun falan diye çok da
eleştiri aldım ama ben İnanıyordum Bu
ürünlerin satacağını ve müşterilerle Eee
direkt onları anlatıyordum bu yöresel
ürünlerin ne kadar önemli olduğunu 2015
yılında ikinci malzeme açtım 2016
yılında üçüncü Şarküteri malzeme açtım
ve artık temas markası biraz daha
bilinir hale gelmişti ve şehir dışında
da artık tanınmaya başlamıştık
Tabii bu kadar yöresel ürünün Bir de
yöreselliği anlatan bir ismi olmalıydı o
zaman rahmetli annemin önerisiyle çaman
markasını koymaya verdim koymaya karar
verdim ama o zamandan Hayallerim ilk
baştan beri benim çok büyüktü bu kadar
yöresel ürünler dünyaya tanıtılmalı diye
düşünüyordum Çok Global bir isim
olmalıydı yanına eş takısını getirdim
cemaat marka tescilinde aldım
[Alkış]
pastırma
bastırma gerçekten dünyada en iyi üreten
şehir biz
ve pastırma iyi olduğu kadar dilimlemesi
de çok önemli biliyorsunuz pastırma iyi
dilimlenmezse zaten yenmez ve pastırma
ustaları bizim şehrimizde gerçekten bir
onlar sanatkar diyorum sanatçılar Ama bu
pastırma doğrama işine artık Çok da
gençler rağbet göstermiyordu geçen sene
belediyeye bir proje sundum dedim ki
pastırma dilimleme ustası kursu açalım
çok ilgi gördü mağaza müdürümüz gitti 3
ay kurs verdi
kültürel mirasımızı korumak sahiplenmek
gerçekten çok önemli Şimdi ben gençlere
bu kültürel mirasımızın ne kadar önemli
olduğunu anlatmaya çalışıyorum bu işten
çok da güzel paralar kazanıyorlar
pastırma dilimleme ustalarının daha da
çok yetişmesi için
çalışıyoruz çabalıyoruz
2019 yılında dedim ya şehir dışında daha
iyi tanıyoruz Biz diye 2019 yılında ilk
ödülümü aldım Türkiye'nin en iyi satış
noktası ödülünü
Evet yöresel ürünler dedik bastırma
sucuk dedik ama mantımız da bir o kadar
önemliydi bizim için
mantının ana vatanı Kayseri el mantısı
çok önemli bir ürün ve ben satışta Evde
yaptığımız gibi mantı bulamıyordum dedim
ki kendi mantığımı kendim üretmeliydim
atölye kurmaya karar verdim
Herkesin hayatında bazı dönüm noktaları
vardır benim dönüm noktalarımdan ilki
çalışmak oldu İkincisi de atölye açmak
oldu mantı üretmek için
atölyeye girdik Ben iki kişiyle başladım
üretime ama evde yapılanı benzemiyordu
mantı üretmek o kadar da kolay değildi
daha çok kadına ihtiyaç vardı
çevremdeki tüm kadınlara davet ettim
atölyeme gelin burada dolduralım mantıyı
dedim ama o dönemde mantı hep evlerde
dolduruluyor ve satılıyordu
ilk başta sıcak bakmadılar tabii ki ama
çok mücadele verdim
ailelerin ikna etmek gerekiyordu çünkü
mantı doldurarak para kazanacaklarını
düşünmüyorlardı
onlara davet ettim ve bayağı bir
mücadele ettik sonrasında onları
inandırmıştım ve ekibimi kurdum
artık Mantı doldurduğumuz yer
atölyemiz bizim için
sosyalleştiğimiz kadının evden çıkması
gerekiyordu çünkü kadın hem para
kazanacak Hem sosyalleşecekti şimdi bu
alan
mantığı doldurma alanımız artık bizim
için sosyalleştiğimiz etkinlikler
düzenlediğimiz eğitim yaptığımız bir yer
haline gelmişti
mantı satmak için giriştiğim
atölyemizde artık o iş benim için o
kadınların Hayat mücadelelerini
dinledikten sonra hayatlarına Tanık
olduktan sonra benim için bambaşka bir
şey ifade ediyordu artık ben bu işi
bırakamazdım Çünkü bunun arkasında
bambaşka şeyler vardı tabii bu kadar işi
ben kendi başıma yapmadım
ilk baştan beri marka ismimiz bile yoktu
o zaman benim hayallerime inanan bana
güvenen benimle koşan çok güçlü bir
ekibim vardı Onlara da buradan çok çok
teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]
gün Eee gün yüzüne çıkması gereken çok
fazla ürün vardı Şimdi onları çıkartmaya
başladık biz ee Kayseri'de ve Anadolu'da
dışarıda yemek yemek kültürü çok yaygın
değildir herkes yöresel yemeğini evde
yapar yer çünkü en çok eşinin ve
ailesinin bunu çok iyi yaptığını düşünür
Eee ama şehir dışından gelen
misafirlerin bu bu yemeği yöresel
yemeklerimizi yemeye ihtiyaçları vardı
Ve bu açığı Restoran açığını gördük ve
restoran içine girdik
2016 yılında ilk restoranımızı aştık
gün yüzüne çıkmamış özel çok yöresel
yemeklerimiz vardı onları tanıtmaya
başladık eski sunum şekilleriyle eski
reçeteleriyle üretiyorduk zaten Ama
bizim kendi yediğimiz sunum şekilleriyle
de restoranda müşterilerimize tanıtmaya
başladık gastronomi dünyasından insanlar
çok ilgi gösterdi ürünlerimizi
Bunlardan en ünlüsü tepsi mantısı tepsi
mantısını çok güzel tanıttık anlattık ve
ilk ödülünü aldı tepsi mantısı Hürriyet
gazetesinden 100 yemeğinden biri oldu
tepsisi mantısı şimdi Tüm Türkiye'de 5
yıldızlı otellerin mutfağına girdi lüks
restoranların menüsüne girdi tepsi
mantısı üreticileri de oldu
[Alkış]
şimdi Kayseri mantısını coğrafi işaret
belgesini de aldık bu arada
almıştık sonrasında Diğer ürünlerle
birlikte 8 üründe coğrafi işaret belgesi
aldık Kayseri'ye özgü Çünkü ben bu işe
girdiğimde Kayseri mantısı adı altında o
kadar çok mantı üreticisi vardı ki Ama
Kayseri'de değildi Kayseri'de Belki
%20'ydi o kadar söyleyeyim ama bizim bu
ürünü Çok doğru anlatmamız tanıtmamız
gerekiyordu fuarlara gitmeye başladık
ulusal fuarlara git Ee sır ha
Uluslararası bir fuardır üç yıl üst üste
gittik
gastro masaya gittik Geçen sene
para kendi günleri feslumitler ve ben
gittiğimde sürekli yöresel ürünlerimizi
anlatıyordum tanıtmaya çalışıyordum
ve bunu ekiple yapıyorduk Tabii ki çok
ilgi gösterdik astronomi Dünyası
geçen sene
pop-up restoranla İstanbul'da
zorlu'da İtalya
hizmeti verdik 3 ay Bu ikinci
gidişimizdi ikinci sefer davet edildik
İtalyan İtalya'nın yöresel yemeklerinin
yanında Kayseri'nin ve Anadolu'nun
yöresel yemeklerini birlikte sunmanın
gururunu yaşadık
Ayrıca geçen sene yazın BBC televizyonu
İngiltere geldi pastırmanın yapılış
hikayesini anlattık
[Alkış]
tabii böyle
hala devam ediyor Ben şehrimin Şehrime
yöresel yemeklerine sahip çıkmak
yeni nesillere aktarmak gibi misyon
edindim
bunu da en iyi şekilde yapmaya
çalışıyorum
eskiden gelen bizim bağ kültüründe
yaşadığım o Çocukluğumda yediğim Van
kültüründen Doğan yöresel yemekleri
yemeklere sahip çıkmak eski reçeteleri
ile annemin anneannemin Kayınvalidemin
yaptığı yemekleri herkese tanıtmak
istiyorum en büyük şansım da o zaman
onlar hayattayken
birebir onlara yaptığım her ürünü
tattırıyor ve onay almam ona yanmamdı
gerçekten benim için de çok kıymetli bir
deneyimdi
birkaç bir şey söylemek istiyorum
özellikle gençlere ben
bu işe geç başladım
başladığımda da gerçekten çok
eleştirildim ilk başta kimse inanmıyordu
Çünkü bana herkes Ömür biçmişti mesela
iki yıl sonra kapatır bir yıl sonra işte
vazgeçer diyorlardı
çok da sıkıntı çektim ama hiçbir zaman
vazgeçmedim Çünkü ben işime tutkuyla
bağlıyım
ve
bunu Ben kiminle şu anda çemense
anlatmak istiyorum Size 80 kişilik bir
ekibimiz var şehir merkezinde 3
Şarküteri mağazamız var bir restoranımız
var
atölye o zaman 150 metrekare atölye şu
anda 2000 metrekare bir üretim tesisi
haline dönüştü %90 kadın istihdamıyla
çalışıyorum
üretim merkezi
üretim merkezini kurarken Dedik ki bir
sloganımız olsun bizim ne yapabiliriz
hayal et Cesur o üret mutlu ol kendinize
inanın İşte o zaman güzel şeyler olmaya
başlar dedik
[Alkış]
ve devam ediyoruz
hayata gelme sebebinin sebebinin üretken
olup önce kendime sonra aileme sonra da
toplum yararına olduğuna inanıyorum önce
kızlarım için sonra tüm kız çocukları ve
kadınlarımız için de ilham kaynağı olmak
istiyorum
[Alkış]
Ben de Başka kadınlardan ilham aldığım
gibi çok teşekkür ediyorum sağ olun
[Alkış]